so i'm thinking about hardware devices
essentially physical representatives of
these cloud services
which makes them actually very different
than traditional consumer electronics so
historically a company made an
electronic product you know say a
turntable and then they found people who
would sell it for them then they
advertised it heavily and people bought
them and that was the end of their
relationship with that customer until
they were able to convince that person
to buy another one
so that is the entire value of that
relationship had to be packaged within
the device itself which is you know my
pet theory is that that's why they used
to put like heavy metal plates in a
consumer electronics so they would feel
like you were getting more value out of
them
with the internet of things
the sale of the device is actually just
the beginning of the relationship it's
not the end of the relationship it's the
beginning of the relationship and the
physical thing actually holds almost no
value for either the consumer or the
manufacturer
value now shifts to services and the
devices
the devices the software applications
and you know the websites the apps that
are used to access it i call those
things avatars
they're physical representatives of a
thing that's up in the clouds right
uh
so i also want to steal it back from the
vr people
uh
that was totally wrong so anyway um so a
camera becomes a really good appliance
for taking photos for instagram a tv
becomes a really nice way to display
instagram photos that you don't have to
log into every time you can show people
at a party a phone becomes a really
convenient way both to take photos and
to check your friends photos photo
streams or kanye's when you're on the
road
hardware the physical things in this
situation become simultaneously more
specialized and devalued as people see
through each device to the service it
represents people don't care about the
device they care about the service the
avatars exist in order to get better
uh value out of the service amazon
really gets this so you know here's a
telling older ad from amazon for the
kindle
what it's saying is look use whatever
device you want we don't care as long as
you stay loyal to our service you can
buy one of our specialized devices that
we lose money on every time
on purpose
because the value is in the service but
you can use some other way to access our
service and then we won't have to lose
money on that on the device
when fire was launched and it was
originally kindle fire now you know you
have fire stick and fire phone uh you
know r.i.p not really in ip but anyway
uh w
when uh
those of you who are two of those who
get that joke anyway so when uh uh
when fire was released bezos even called
it a service it is not a device it is
not a thing it is a service
amazon dash
is a service that's enabled by dedicated
devices this is a real thing so you can
buy
a watching machine from whirlpool or ge
that will reorder its own supplies it
will reorder its own uh
its own
tide when it's running out of tide will
reorder its own bleach runs toronto
beach you can buy this today this is
enabled by amazon's dash service and the
reason that amazon made this
is so that they wouldn't have to make
these devices you know shipping all that
metal is really expensive why should we
making it why should we take the
why should we take the hit on uh doing
the r d for a washing machine when we
can take all the profit by selling the
tide
so
amazon also for things that don't uh
speak the amazon dash service they'll
sell you a button for it so here's a
tied button
this is a networked computer that you
can buy for five dollars whose entire
purpose is to order you tied
every single time you push the button it
will order you tied
and only tied
here you can pass it around
don't be ordering me tied my uh
so so so so you can so if you look here
you can't see so the the the top one
so the top one is mac macaroni and
cheese the bottom one is uh is minced
these are services uh that are
effectively
pri
preparing you for infinitely
automatically replenishable macaroni and
cheese
it's a macaroni and cheese service that
you will buy into so you never have to
think about buying macaroni and cheese
again
the margins on this are insane
so most large-scale center
most large-scale internet things
products are service avatars like this
they don't they use specialized sensors
and actuators to support a service but
they have very little value or they
don't even work at all without the
supporting service like it's just like
your phone your phone if you cancel your
contract doesn't really work i mean the
wi-fi works but you know theoretically
doesn't really work
um when smartthings was acquired by
samsung um they clearly state their
service offering upfront and tell you
very little about what the stuff does
what the service offers is that they
will help you be home wherever you are
they don't tell you how that's what what
they're going to do what does their
hardware do you don't know you don't
care you shouldn't care
compare that to x10
their spiritual predecessor who's been
around since the tandy color computer
all x10 tells you about its white
plastic boxes is what they are not what
they will accomplish for you like i
don't even know if there is a service
why should i care that they have modules
what the i don't
and i i shouldn't either and i don't
so i think that the real value that
connected services offer is their
ability to make sense of the world on
our behalf to reduce cognitive load by
enabling people to interact with the
world with devices at a higher level
than simple data than simple telemetry
at the level of intentions and goals
rather than data and control
humans are not built to make sense of
huge amounts of data across many devices
or to articulate our needs as systems of
mutually interdependent components
computers are great all that
[Music]
you